when a smile says it all tristan
thompson is enjoying some daddy daughter
time with his baby girl true
the nba player posted this snap with the
three-year-old whom he shares with khloe
kardashian the pick comes just weeks
after the athlete admitted to fathering
a child with marlene nichols while he
was still in a relationship with chloe
nichols gave birth to her baby boy on
december 1st and after taking a
paternity test tristan made a public
apology to chloe posting a lengthy
statement to his instagram story that
read in part quote i take full
responsibility for my actions chloe you
don't deserve this you don't deserve the
heartache and humiliation i have caused
you you don't deserve the way i have
treated you over the years
now a source is opening up to et about
where coco and tristan stand today
explaining that of course the basketball
pro wants to get back together but
chloe's current mindset wants a player
always a player i'm someone who i do
like to put my relationships as a
priority and i try to make i really try
to make that work the source adds that
the reality star is ready to write a new
chapter and will continue focusing on
true while balancing a healthy
co-parenting relationship with tristan
the source reveals quote it would take a
miracle for them to get back together at
this point i think everyone has to
handle their co-parenting situation in
their own style
coco always keeps it real especially
when it comes to raising kids and in
2019 she opened up about how her parents
set an example after divorcing my mom
and my dad were like that it took them
years but my dad would come over once a
week for family dinners and would play
golf with my stepdad and so we come from
a family where we believe in that and
you share children with people and
that's how it should be
[Music]
the trailer for the kardashians new hulu
series just dropped and now fans are
curious how much of chloe and tristan's
relationship we'll get to see when it
begins streaming april 14th
we're streaming and we get to have a
much quicker turnaround than previously
and we're really excited they're here
now in the back shooting with us and
we're so happy to be you know up and
rolling again
[Music]
you